I hate intros haikyuu season what really
kicked things off of the introduction of
the main character show you Hinata as a
child who happens to see the national
high school volleyball championship on
TV whose newfound idol nicknamed Little
Giant plays for COD asuno high and
despite his vertically challenged
endeavors still manages to be the team's
ace now we jump ahead three years and
three months where Hinata is joined by
his friends Azumi and Koji at their
first volleyball tournament in junior
high school
their first game is a pretty massive
mismatch when they go against ki Tagawa
Daiichi junior high we get our first
look at Kageyama tobio who is known as
the king of the court or just king for
short as the match starts we see that
cocky ama is a really good setter but
doesn't get along with his teammates
because of his tryhard attitude plus
he's toxic is where you get a flashback
over the past three years where Hinata
was obsessed with practicing but there
were no boys who played volleyball at
his school
despite that he would still practice by
himself and constantly beg his friends
to help him by the end of the match
Hinata and his friends obviously lost
but his determination and speed got him
noticed by Kageyama jump ahead a year to
the president at kata suno high where
Hinata is now attending following in the
footsteps of his idol The Little Giant
to his surprise and dismay his rival
from the junior high tournament Kageyama
is at kata suno as well episode 2 we
learned that the best school had
rejected Kageyama so he had to settle
for kata suna the other both of them
meet the current upperclassmen on the
volleyball team we have the captain
Daichi Sawa muta set her and vice
captain ko she sugawara and a
second-year Wing Spiker Rihanna's skate
Annika we learned that the school once
attended nationals which is when the
little giant was on the team now on the
other hand they're ranked eighth in the
prefecture considered neither strong nor
weak earning themselves the titles
fallen rivals and the crows that can't
fly
anyways we get introduced to Cutie chant
Yuko Shimazu who is part of management
there are currently four first-year
applicants trying to get onto the
volleyball team so they set up a 3v3 to
figure out where they are in terms of
skill Tonica is assigned to play with
Hinata and Kageyama against the other
sheers and one other upperclassman II
episode 3 in preparation for the
scrimmage Hinata and Kageyama show up
before school to practice and practice
after school until the Sun Goes Down
they are interrupted by the other two
first-year applicants and their
opponents kaizuka Shima and Tadashi
Yamaguchi Fukushima is kind of a douche
when he starts calling Kageyama King
which he hates and it almost escalates
into a fight in the meantime they keep
up their rigorous practice schedule
until their match day II episode 4
captain died she decides to be their
opponents third to make the team's even
and the match gets underway Hinata is
excited to be getting set up by such a
talented setter but suka Shima's hype
makes it difficult to score as he blocks
all of his spikes
Kageyama takes a different approach to
utilize he matches insane speed will
compensate him for his lack of
experience this results in a nasty quick
attack where Kageyama uses his pinpoint
accuracy to bring the ball to Hinata
allowing him to focus on moving at max
speed it's extremely effective when it
works but they still need to refine it
as they keep messing it up II episode 5
each side takes a game off of the other
and afterwards the first-years
officially get into the club and are
given their team jackets immediately
after it's a two takata at the club
advisor Burson saying that their first
practice match has been set up against a
Lobo Josiah High School it's also the
schoolwork Haga Yama's old teammates
play and they are the ones who gave him
the title King which is an insult saying
that he was an egocentric King he of his
own six
jhope ahead to the practice match where
we meet the Alba Jo side players back to
the game he not to plays awful because
of his nerves and even hits Kageyama in
the back of the head with the serve
needless to say the first set is a bit
of stuff however after some not so
subtle intimidation from Kageyama Hinata
is able to go back to normal they use
our combo effectively in the second set
answered the surprise of Kageyama old
teammates he shows that he is more of a
team player now episode 7 part of the
reason they were able to take his set is
because the opposition's team captain
and starting setter toto Okawa showed up
late
he is also Cagayan his old upperclassman
that taught him how to play in the third
set it gets down to game point when they
decide to sub in oikawa who's now done
with his warmups he is also their pinch
server so he searched with intense speed
and accuracy targeting sakushima since
he is a weak receiver
luckily they recover allowing Hinata and
Kageyama to set up yet another nasty
combo winning them the match even though
they won they realized that there's a
lot of room for improvement especially
in terms of defense and receiving the
episode 8 now we get introduced to you
nishinoya
kata sunos Libra which specializes in
defense he got a little riled up before
the first year's arrived so he was
banned from club activities for a month
there is a slight problem though as he
refuses to come back until their ace
returns to the team as well we're then
hop on over to Takeda who's trying to
recruit KC no Kai to be the new
volleyball coach finishings grandfather
was the old coach at kata suna during
the Little Giant era but had retired
leaving the team without any proper
guidance
keen says that he doesn't want to be the
coach but talkative vows to not give up
until he does the next day we meet the
ACE refusing to play ASSA he assumed
money as sugawara tries to convince him
to come back but to no avail
meanwhile everybody else gets ready for
golden week training camp where they
have another practice match scheduled at
the end of it against nekima hi episode
9 KC and hears about the match with
nekima who used to be kata sunos rival
he doesn't what his successors to
embarrass the kata suno name so he
decides he will coach them until then
after pulling some strings he gets
players from the Neighborhood
Association team to come help them
practice the air shorts and players so I
say he is reluctantly pulled into the
scrimmage well playing his reminded of
the brutal defeat they suffered which
led to him and Isha Noah getting into an
argument causing him to
and Misha noia to get issued his
month-long ban during the match they put
all of this behind them and the ace of
kata Sunna returns to his former glory
in epic fashion episode 10 most of this
episode is about he not too realizing
that his position as decoy is just as
valuable as the a switches to the
position he was shooting for to be like
Little Giant the Neighborhood
Association go on to win the match but
in the end they learned a lot and played
a good game ah so he is brought back as
a starter with his determination to play
back in full swing
this means that nishinoya is now also
willing to play as the Lovato giving
them a formidable roster II episode 11
the training camp gets underway and
everybody is working hard on their
receives to tighten up their defenses on
the day of their match against nekima
they get their new uniforms and Hinata
gets number 10 which just so happened to
be the number of the little giant
they're reminded of how tough their
opponents are having never lost to kata
suno even when the little giant was on
their team II episode 12 we arrived at
the day of the match and we meet the
nekima team Kurata cirno takes an early
lead but Koza mae analyzes their play
and uses big brain tactics to start
countering Hinata this custom the first
set after nekima starts to learn how to
protect Hinata z' movements in the
second set Hinata is getting completely
shut down so in response he tries to
learn how to use accuracy to get through
the blocker
Kageyama tries to accommodate him by
altering his set so it floats a little
longer adding to their overall arsenal
episode 13 they switch between that
quote-unquote zoomy set and floating set
to keep them guessing however this isn't
enough as they are still maturing as a
team and after playing six sets against
nekima they lose every single one this
makes everyone more determined and
renews the longtime rivalry between the
two schools
episode 14 the inter-high preliminaries
are just around the corner so everybody
is working extra hard out of the 60
teams in the prefecture only one will go
to Nationals and it's single elimination
so one loss and you're out the brackets
are released and they learn a bit more
about the stronger teams entering the
tournament
Yamaguchi doesn't want to be the only
first-year who
set things out so he goes to one of the
players from the Neighborhood
Association team Mikasa Shimada he asked
him to teach him how to do jumping boat
service which he was demonstrating
during their scrimmage episode 15 no we
jump ahead to the start of the inner
high preliminaries with our boys showing
up in style their first opponent is toku
nami hi now it's the moment they've all
been working for at their first official
match and things get off to a great
start with kata suna taking an early
lead episode 16 good as soon I continue
to outclass their opponent not even
having to use their insane quick yet
just sticking to normal ones we then get
a quick look at kata soon as girls
volleyball team with daichi's future
waifu you ain't me shamea trying to
rally because they are trash hey don't
and lose just like token ami who can't
even take a set-up of goddess uno they
advance out of the second round but the
next match isn't going to be as easy
because they are up against dots a tech
high the teams slogan is iron wall of
day because of their impervious defenses
this is also the team that shut down us
he's so hard that he quits so now is his
opportunity for redemption II episode 17
as the match gets underway kata cirno
takes the lead but it's sloppy and
really they're getting more lucky than
they are out playing the defenses we
begin to get later into the game and the
iron wall starts to live up to its name
shutting them down repeatedly with them
losing momentum they decide it's time to
use their free quick with Hinata
they executed flawlessly leaving
everybody speechless and wondering if it
was just luck
the second time they bust out there
quick confirms to dot a tech that it
wasn't luck so they need to marquee not
a all cost but I doing this they play
right into he knots his role as the
decoy allowing the ace Asahina shine RIA
in the episode with a score of 1915 in
favor of Goddess uno but all of goddess
Uno's arsenal is now known to Dante Tex
so now it's up to them to figure out how
to respond yeah episode 18 goddess uno
goes on to win the first set 25 to 19
but towards the end you can tell that
Dante is starting to find their rhythm
number 7 takenoko
ona proves to be a bit of a problem as
he is their best blocker when he's in
their vanguard he mark Sonata
effectively shutting down some of their
free quicks if this series goes to a
third match got a pseudo Mike yet figure
it out and shut down they claw their way
ahead in the second set and even though
ASSA he gets blocked numerous times he
keeps calling for the ball proving why
he is considered the ACE he powers
through the wall scoring the final point
and advancing them to the next round
episode 19 after that match they are
done for the day so they watch Ocala and
Alba Jos I play in their matches which
they win when they head back they see
that the tournament was broadcasted on
the local news well watching they
learned that the defending champions are
also a massive threat led by Walker
Toshi Ashima they slaughter their
opponents 25 to 6 but anyways for the
third round they get their rematch
against OB Jo side things are gonna be a
bit different this time because Oh a cow
is gonna be playing so it's time to see
if Kageyama has surpassed his teacher e
episode 20 the two setters go blow for
blow both scoring points early on but
they know a cow it calls for an early
timeout after reviewing footage from
cata Sooners games he had figured out
that he notches call-outs
are a sign for what quick to use he
tells us to the team and it makes it
even harder for cata sooner to get
traction in the match as they fall more
and more behind
Kageyama is feeling the pressure of
playing against his mentor and it's
reflecting in his play they don't seem
to be making any progress and they need
a change so in the last scene Kageyama
is taken out for suka whadda
episode 21
this change of pace is exactly what the
team needed and seiga wada uses his
experience to perform well under the
pressure he is also able to give
everybody some pointers on how to handle
the opposition spikes based on what he
observed from the earlier play the
massive deficit combined with a cow was
monster serves are too much to overcome
though and they lose the first set in
the second set they realize that they
need to find an answer to a cow was
served they shift their position to
increase the odds of Daiichi or
nishinoya receiving the serve which
works perfectly gah Guiana seems to be
back in his normal mindset so they
decide it's time to reinitiate the
deadly duo II episode 22 with Cagayan
back in the game they go on the
offensive switching up their quicks
again they also change up their signals
so that the attacks aren't as
transparent to the defenders Kageyama
being the try-hard he is also tries to
emulate suka wadis friendly behavior to
bolster the morale of the team instead
of getting caught up in his head this is
definitely a work in progress but
everybody seems to appreciate the
sentiment and the effort that he's
putting forward to inspire them he even
tries to communicate with suka she might
even though the two have never really
gotten along with one another it's not
like they're friends now or anything but
it's a little bit less tense this all
comes together nicely and they go on to
win a closed set 25 to 23 episode 23 the
last set gets underway and Hinata uses a
broad attack where he swings to the
outside faster than the blockers in
order to score to combat this they
stopped sending blockers after him and
instead send early below to receive the
spike in stead countering part of their
arsenal good as soon as starts to fall
behind again
so Kay she tries to think of a way to
break their momentum he decides to put
in Yamaguchi as their pinch server to
try and get them some easy points with
his jump float serve that he's been
working on needless to say the pressure
is on and he can't handle it leading to
him botching his first and only sir even
though he didn't score they still had a
nice change in momentum and Kat Asuna
starts their comeback both teams trade
back and forth until eventually we get
tied at 24 to 24
conveniently segue into episode 24 once
both teams are tied at 24 you have to
get ahead by two points in order to
when goddess uno takes the first lead
but is immediately answered back this
continues for a while until it gets to
be 31 - 31 and unfortunately Okawa is up
to serve the Bish's serve ends up
leading to a quick point getting them
ahead and back to match point
after a long volley between the two
teams kaua is able to predict Kageyama
x' next play which allows the defense to
shut it down winning them the match
everyone is devastated but being such a
new team they realize that there is
still a lot of progress to be made
yepez Oh 25 the next day everybody goes
back to their normal schedules at school
while the third and final day of the
tournament plays out Laurie Keller gets
a rematch with his longtime rival Ujima
and the defending champs XI Natori zawa
meanwhile over to the third-years who
were asked to think about their future
and maybe stop volleyball to focus on
studying we all know that's not
happening and everybody is right back to
practice back over to the finals sheet
authorities alwah defend their title
without dropping a set
securing their spot in nationals even
though they lost it's now time for kata
Soota to set their sights on the spring
tournament which will be the last chance
for the thirty-years to secure a title
yeah we hop on over to the OVA x' where
we follow nekima high after they lost at
the inner high preliminaries for Tokyo
after the loss they are looking for some
new blood and find it in the form of her
first year named love hiya hi blah is a
bot and can't even spike a ball but he
has a lot of potential the episode
revolves around him trying to find his
groove with the setter Koza Mae and it
looks like he might become a real threat
I'm gonna be doing the future seasons
and that'll be in the bottom left
whenever I'm finished with it or you can
check out all the high Q recaps in this
playlist here you can also find the
links in the description below and the
only thing I hate more than intros is
outro